le stic est partout un même message tout
doit être fait pour freiner la caf les
de 19 des mesures on est dans une crise
qui va durer dix mois on est clair qu on
brime un peu les droits individuels mais
c'est pour le bien collectif faut se
préparer des six de west publique porter
une attention spéciale aux personnes
vulnérables
c'est la confiance dans la science c'est
d'écouter celles et ceux qui savent
concernant l'avenir on est en train
chaque heureux de regarder la situation
et jetons et kuoni capables tous
ensemble de passer au travail
[Musique]
alors bienvenue cette émission spéciale
de deux heures pour comprendre comment
on peut freiner la coville de 19 ce
fameux virus coronavirus donc des
mesures draconiennes sont mises en place
donc d'entendre des extraits du jour et
avec cet appel à la prudence aussi un
appel au calme et à la solidarité
au cours des deux prochaines heures nous
ferons le bilan de ce que vous devez
savoir de ce que l'on vit en ce moment
collectivement dans le pays et de ce qui
nous attend les prochaines heures
prochains jours prochaines semaines et
peut-être prochains mois on verra bien
nous experts répondront aussi à
certaines de vos questions
mais invité ce soir sur le plateau dr
karl weiss microbiologiste infectiologue
docteur christine brouh président de
l'ordre des psychologues du québec dr
cécile tremblay microbiologistes
infectiologues et le docteur horacio
arruda directeur national de la santé
publique du québec
bonsoir à vous quatre merci de nous
accompagner au cours de ces dix
prochaines heures et aussi julie est mon
parce que les tests les téléspectateurs
julie vont pouvoir nous écrire au cours
de l'émission dont nous faire prendre de
nouvelles questions parce qu'on en a
déjà beaucoup quand même
exactement dans la rue tout au long de
la semaine anne marie à votre demande à
votre appel que vous avez lancé aux
téléspectateurs aux gens à la maison
mais ont fait appel à vous encore une
fois pour nous envoyer vos questions vos
commentaires vos réactions tout au long
de l'émission fut le faire surtout été
avec le mot-clé caire 10 24 60 fait nous
écrire par courriel à l'adresse
habituelle 24-70 robin
radio canada.ca ou encore sur la page
facebook de radio canada
info on fait un bref portrait un état
des lieux d'où on se trouve à l'heure
actuelle à l'échelle pancanadienne est
important de le rappeler
commençons par ce qui se passe dans
l'est dans les provinces de l'atlantique
une seule province touchée jusqu'à
présent c'est le nouveau brunswick qui a
donc déclaré un premier cas confirmé
aujourd'hui ils étaient présumés hier
mais aujourd'hui on a bel et bien
confirmé donc à la suite des analyses de
laboratoire d'infectiologie de
microbiologie plutôt de winnipeg vous
dire qu'au nouveau brunswick pour
l'instant la mesure qu'on annonce et
c'est qu'on suspend jusqu'à nouvel ordre
les procès devant jury dont premier
première initiative de ce côté pour le
gouvernement néo-brunswickois
au québec on est à 13 cas confirmés pour
le moment aucun cas probable nous dit on
il ya eu beaucoup d'annoncés de ce côté
en d'abord d'une part
du point de vue de la ville de montréal
la mairesse les plantes qui a annoncé en
fin de journée aujourd'hui la fermeture
de nombreux lieux publics on pense à des
arènes à des salles de spectacles des
lieux également comme le planétarium la
biosphère et j'en passe bien sûr pas
encore de fermeture sur le métro de
montréal mais on surveille la situation
de près en ce qui concerne les
transports collectifs et plus tôt
aujourd'hui il ya eu justement de
nombreux points de presse de nombreuses
questions adressées à nos élus notamment
au premier ministre françois legault qui
a annoncé des mesures particulières
draconiennes la première de celles-ci
françois legault recommande de se
classer en isolement préventif pendant
14 jours au retour d'un séjour à
l'étranger ou encore si on a des
symptômes s'apparentant à la coved 19
mais ça c'est une recommandation par
contre pour tous les employés de l'état
qui travaillent soit comme fonctionnaire
ou encore qui sont dans des dans des
milieux de garde garderie école donc en
milieu d'éducation ou encore dans le
milieu de la santé bien là cette
directive est obligatoire nous dit on
deux autres mesures particulières le
premier ministre legault qui demande à
tous les organisateurs d'événements
publics de plus de 250 personnes qui ont
lu à l'intérieur des événements dont à
l'intérieur de bâtiments d'annuler tous
ses événements jusqu'à nouvel ordre et
québec recommande en terminant aux
citoyens d'annuler tout événement
justement toute participation à un
événement public qui n'est pas
absolument nécessaire je termine avec
les autres provinces
un coup d'oeil en ontario on est
présentement rendu à 60 cas confirmés
mais il y en a plus de 530 en cours
d'analysé
vraiment tout n'est pas démis une
propagation très rapide en ontario c'est
pourquoi un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui on
a annoncé la fermeture de toutes les
écoles publiques et ce au moins jusqu'au
5 avril prochain il faut dire que la
semaine prochaine c'est la semaine de
relâche en ontario mais donc on y va de
mesures préventives
il ya aussi un bébé qui a été contaminé
un petit garçon de moins d'un an qui a
donc eu un contact étroit avec un
patient contaminé manitoba saskatchewan
deux cas probables donc un dans chacune
de ces deux provinces on est rendu à 23
qu'en alberta dont le premier enfant au
pays avant bébé en ontario c'était un
jeune enfant dans une garderie garderie
qui est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
côté de calgary et en colombie
britannique 7 nouveaux cas divulguer
dans la dernière heure on est donc à 53
en incluant bien sûr les premières
victimes au pays l'occupation qui est
décédé qui était âgé de plus de 80 cents
alors merci julie donc vous pouvez
inviter les téléspectateurs à nous
écrire parce que vous allez
rendre compte de leurs questions merci
menacée j'ai commencé avec vous dr
arruda si vous voulez bien beaucoup
dénoncent aujourd'hui sur les mesures
particulières du québec qu'est ce qui
les a guidés ces mesures particulières
notamment l'endroit de l'interdiction
d'avoir des rassemblements de plus de
250 personnes ou encore à l'endroit des
voyageurs mais dans le fond il faut
comprendre que ces députés mais n'agit
mondiale et notre épidémie déjà que ce
stade on est rendus qui nous amène à
prendre ces mesures parce que un des
objectifs plus profonds voyez ce qui est
arrivé en italie un système de santé
quand même de bonne qualité qui est
surchargée absolument parce que il ya eu
une augmentation rapide du nombre
d'accords et l'om est recommande
notamment plus de maisons de santé
publique classique qui sont importantes
implanté justement avant qu'on perde le
contrôle ou avant qu'on soit très
contaminée et le québec a un profil où
les corps proviennent pas seulement de
chine
exeter c'est beaucoup plus le cas encore
on dit annick mais ici au québec dont le
des coques sont venus d'italie de france
d'ailleurs d'europe donc on a un autre
profil passé associe souvent aux
voyageurs qui atterrissent à certains
territoires
dans ce contexte là et dans un contexte
où ça s'est un peu partout pour les
chiffres sont pas toujours fiables
nous on pense que le voyage des mesures
autour du voyage sont majeurs pour
diminuer le bombardement
je peux dire du virus qui rentre au
québec et deux mesures
ici au québec pour éviter la
transmission
éventuellement des mesures qui vont être
suivis et décidé au jour le jour aussi
agité au jour le jour
c'est pour ça qu'on peut y avoir des
points de presse quotidiens et ça ça
fait partie des questions aussi des
habitudes et je tiens à vous dire c'est
à la fois nos cliniciens rebecchi qui
vont être pris avec le traitement des
patients mais à la fois toutes les
entreprises tout le québec
tous les citoyens doivent présider geste
particulièrement aussi pour protéger nos
plus vénérables non plus à jupe et
c'était au fait que puis je le répèterai
pas assez les vaches de ménages de mai
mais les mesures qu'on veut faire c'est
pour aplatir une courbe
on peut la regarder cette wave le
tableau vous allez pouvoir nous
l'expliqué elle s'en vient la courbe
parce que l'idée de freiner de ralentir
parce que ce que vous avez quand même
dit aujourd'hui docteur arruda
c'est de dire qu'on a qu'on en a encore
pour un bon buteur
oui il faut comprendre que ça partira
pas comme ça dont une population qui est
vierge ou virus la coupe vous voyez la
courbe rouge soit ceci en 1 puis une
ligne avouer qu'il est resté dix thèmes
quand on a une épidémie qui arrive qui
montrait très rapidement on va se
retrouver dans une situation où
rapidement vos dépasse la capacité du
système et c'est là le cancer et
beaucoup de quand même temps
heureusement beaucoup de costumes seront
pas très malade mais il va y avoir des
spas cinq mondes citer les soins de
travail ou de docteur ici somme est
important de vol assez de soins
intensifs etc
si on est capable trop bien c'est qu'on
va s'agiter un plat qu'il s'agisse à
l'épidémiologie on
mais même si on veut prendre des mesures
puissent ajuster fermer les idées des
affaires moins courante etc
on est mieux d'étaler la courbe d'aller
vers l'autre courbes avec l'autre
couleur de telle sorte qu'à ce moment là
on n'a pas de ce type là est la présence
du système de soins et mes grandes parce
qu'elle ya aussi personnel fo doivent
être présent fixé c'est véritablement
pour ça et nous ms et de façon classique
ces mesures là qui empêche la
transmission dans la communauté
- on a des gens qui font la maladie - on
va avoir des gens qui vont y aller parce
qu'il faut s'y essayer chacun des corps
de génère moins de corps par des
interventions de cette nature-là
d'isolement des interventions que si on
est malade on peut dans certains
événements et surtout pour visiter les
personnes âgées qui sont à plus haut
risque parce que ce qu'on entend depuis
48 heures surtout c'est que ray en 30
jeu peut-être jusqu'à 110 % de la
population qui pourrait être atteint
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
génère une
grande inquiétude vous savez c'est une
invitation à la prudence surtout quand
on dit que ça peut durer longtemps
il faut comprendre que les films de
trente à soixante dix on était un début
d'épidémie on connaît déjà beaucoup de
données sont des expériences différentes
d'un pays à l'autre
il va y avoir des structures de jeux
plus tard pour mieux documenter cd
estimé mais c'est sûr que plus mieux de
corps en même temps plus une probabilité
qu'une proportion de ceux là et besoins
de l'hôpital
donc un petit noyau est 30% de
transmission au moins d'impact à 1,6010
la vérité probablement quelque part
entre les deux mais pas mais mais mais
mais je pense que c'est clair de toute
façon il faut se préparer pour soi par
est-ce que vous anticipez ou appréhender
des scénarios comme à new york ou à des
mesures de contingentement en italie ou
ailleurs à ce que sur le quoi et que ça
va venir
vu que tu ça va dépendre de comment va
se comporter le virus si on un décor un
peu partout au québec mapaq ont fini que
bon je pourrais aussi différents que si
un endroit avec une ecchymose ont bien
démontré
si ça se passe les écoles ou ailleurs
mon départ fermeture c'est possible puis
disons deux entre guillemets quarantaine
pour est toujours un bon trimestre
possible on a plusieurs questions du
public on va aborder tout à l'heure au
cours de l'émission
qu'est ce qui a guidé le choix
d'interdire les races les rassemblements
de 250 personnes et plus pourquoi pas ça
pourquoi pas 50
alors qu on plaide aussi pour une espèce
de distanciation social instance
d'éloignement je devrais être un maître
de vous par exemple
donc qu'est-ce qui guidait le 250 le je
vous le dis le pod d'études de données
probantes pouvait dire que c'est un t
shirt et les cheveux puis c'est parce
qu'on a un événement 225
on ne peut pas la lui laisse ici pas
nécessaire comprenez a été un guide
particulièrement pour les gros
événements et pour les écoles parce que
là il ya dans ailleurs au pays et des
écoles qui vont être fermés il ya des
écoles privées qui annonce la fermeture
des écoles publiques ont seriez encore
il ya quand même beaucoup d'inquiétude
ce sera une étape importante la non de
la fermeture des écoles est ce que cette
partie des scénarios à venir oui tu
t'achètes comme je voulais d'ivoire les
points de presse à chaque jour il peut y
avoir des annonces à chaque jour par
rapport à ces éléments
l'ontario le fait pas c'est le début de
leur semaine de relâche mais nous on on
on est en train de regarder cette
situation là avant d'aller à vos
collègues une question sur ce qui se
passe ailleurs au canada vous avez
mentionné qu'on a une épistémologie tout
à fait particulière on sait par ailleurs
qu'à l'intérieur du canada n'y a pas de
frontières alors les gens il ya des
foyers de contamination ailleurs il ya
un libre passage pour tous les canadiens
qui peuvent venir au québec
est-ce que ce qui se passe ailleurs vous
inquiète quant aux répercussions de ça
pour avoir ici mais ce qui se passe
partout dans le monde nous inquiète
actuellement le pont eu encore le de
transmission intensive dans les autres
provinces qui sont encore à des stades
où il ya plus deux comme lui mais ce que
je le dis aussi c'est que par exemple
les voyages en asie ont été plus
significatif encore britanniques à cause
de la proximité que des voyages en asie
mais vous on s'est tous les voyages que
vous êtes vous parce que vous
recommandez oui srdi plus personnelle la
mort d eau éducation mais pour les
citoyens qui ne sont pas qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas à ces réseaux ces
deux recommandations
c'est une recommandation mais il se faut
qu'ils sachent qu'on vole aussi l'ont
fortement leurs commandes et au retour
notre 14 jouée en isolement volontaire
on apprenait que les services
frontaliers resserrer les mesures
d'accueil
encore une fois pour l'italie l'iran
pour lachine alors que le canada
déconseille d'aller dans plusieurs
autres pays comme espèce de décalage
entre le contrôle pour ce qui arrive que
pour ceux qui partent
sk pas qu'est ce que vous demandez à
town rendement de plusieurs choses
notamment une plus grande présence ou
visualiser à l'arrivée parce que je veux
dire bon il ya des discussions vont
avoir lieu
ils vont avoir effectivement on demande
de l'intervention plus spécifique de
l'information donnée son place comme tel
pour plusieurs types de voyageurs pour
une peau nécessaire parce que je comme
je vous dis nous car chez nous c'est pas
des coques sont arrivés dans ses pas le
seul pays dans l'augmentation des
mesures visibles qui vont être faites
pour que les patients soient informés de
la situation
c'est pas l'impression qu'ils passent à
travers un filet très bien merci dans
content d'être avec nous pour les deux
prochaines heures réaction de votre part
madame
tremblay fait sur un point intéressant
on a appris qu qu'ailleurs au canada en
ontario en colombie-britannique
on parle d'enfants qui sont touchés
pendant qu'on disait que les enfants
étaient vraisemblablement à l'abri le
pourcentage des très faibles je pense
enchaîna plein pour ça en fait les
enfants peuvent être infectés par le
virus et juste qui développe pas une
maladie sévère ou très peu de symptômes
mais c'est pape les enfants ne peuvent
pas être atteints en fait y'a plus de
codes de mortalité chez les enfants
beaux de l'âge de 15 ans je crois donc
ils auront pas de maladie sévère mais ça
veut pas dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
infecté et être des vecteurs de
transmission de la maladie
on ne sait pas encore à quel niveau les
enfants infectés excrète du virus
habituellement on s'éclipse enfin ses 10
buts porteuse de bébé alors même s'ils
sont pas très malade il pourrait
essaimer la maladie et donc l'amener à
leur grand maman papa puis il a causé
des problèmes plus importants des
populations vulnérables
donc c'est quelque chose à surveiller
mais il faut pas penser que les enfants
ne peuvent pas l'attraper de travail
seront ensemble des mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça répond à vos
préoccupations il ya déjà des gens qui
en appelle à des mesures encore plus
draconiennes
il faut y aller au jour le jour où va je
pense d'abord c'est il ya deux choses là
dedans il ya l'aspect de la maladie
infectieuse on a un virus nouveau qui
arrive dans une population non protégé
ou on n'a ni vaccin ni médicaments donc
la seule chose qu'on peut faire c'est
des mesures de confinement de
quarantaine
puis c'est un peu ce qu'on a fait qu'on
a mis en place donc ça c'est l'aspect
maladies infectieuses qui fonctionne
d'ailleurs la seule façon dont la chine
réussit à contrôler finalement c'est
cassé remettant des mesures pareilles
la seule façon dont les pays n'ont pas
réussi à contrôler les cas ça ne mettant
pas des mesures extrêmes
après ça il ya l'aspect je vous dirais
c'est quand même envie dans une société
occidentale ouvertes etc ou de se faire
mettre ce genre de mesures là ça peut
paraître énorme mais c'est courageux de
la part de je dirais du premier ministre
d'avoir mis ce genre de choses là parce
que c'est pas une décision qui est
probablement facile pour la population
générale
ceci étant dit nous ça fait déjà
plusieurs semaines qu'on dit parce que
vous savez que toutes les mesures qu'on
met actuellement faut les préparer
plusieurs semaines en avance par exemple
ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on va devoir
augmenter au québec notre capacité de
faire des tests et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on demandait depuis très
longtemps et qui est extrêmement
important la capacité de dépister aussi
parce que pour que docteur arruda au
niveau de la santé publique
puisse aller chercher où sont les foyers
il faut qu'on puisse identifier qui est
malade et ça c'est un ensemble de
mesures qui vont être très importantes
couplées si vous voulez aux mesures qui
vient d'être mis en place et qui sont de
bonnes mesures
ce qu'on peut se poser comme question
c'est qu'alors qu'on empêche les
québécois de sortir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on laisse importe tout le monde
rentrait et la question revient deux
fois par évidemment et moi je suis un
clinicien j'ai vu des patients ce qui
est intéressant sur l'épidémiologie du
québec c'est qu'on a eu des gens qui
venaient d'un peu partout et surtout on
a eu des surprises
c'est à dire que quand les gens qui
étaient d'un n'était pas sur la liste
ont ils ont fini par avoir du cowitz les
gens qui étaient pas d'europe on a
beaucoup de cas qui origine et en europe
beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs on a des tas
qui se continuent de s'accumuler
donc tout ça ça veut dire que ce nous
d'épidémiologie très saint jean où l'on
doit s'habituer rapidement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que là le voyage ça devient finalement
peu important et qu'il a il va falloir
dépister beaucoup et il va falloir être
capable d'aller tester ces gens là
aiment danser les deux points importants
c'est l'avion va revenir on a plusieurs
questions là dessus ce sont une
sensation s'inspirer de l'expérience
américaine qui est pas très concluante
très probante quant à la capacité de
freiner l'épidémie banane beaucoup ces
mesures qu'est ce que ça vous attend
vous êtes vous êtes certainement comme
président d'honneur de disques apple est
de sensibiliser aux craintes aux
inquiétudes de tête même aux angoisses
que génère une telle situation
oui tout à fait c'est déjà que quand une
menace comme ça ça va augmenter là
l'anxiété chez les gens chez la
population générale particulièrement
chez les gens qui ont déjà une
vulnérabilité ou qui sont déjà anxieux
de nature ou qui sont dans un contexte
anxiogène cela dit l'anxiété est une
réaction normale
c'est ce qui nous permet souvent des
vigiles de nous protéger lors d'une
certaine situation et ça va être
augmenté quand une menace mais quand
elle est nouvelle quand elle est
imprévisible
quand et des situations ambiguës et
quand on n'a pas de contrôle sur la
situation
alors quand on a tout ces éléments là le
les gens deviennent plus anxieux et
c'est patent l'anxiété qui est
problématique parce que l'anxiété je
répète une réaction normale c'est un
phénomène normal devant des situations
comme ça c'est quand elle devient
démesurée que leur île devienne mauvaise
conseillère
on verra comment et quels conseils vous
pouvez donner je perçoive une ligne
d'écouté ou si une ligne d'écouté pour
les gens qui sont très vulnérables qui
ont besoin d'être rassurés madame est
sûr c'est qu'ils sont spéciales se
poursuit au retour avec mes invités et
surtout avec vos questions qui sont très
pertinentes et très nombreux cette année
à
alors le premier ministre ontarien la
veille laisse
lâche en ontario est ce que tous les
ontariens vont venir au québec et de
pêche de la mesa santé qui dit de rester
au canada d'une part et à l'extérieur
donc cette question de propagation du
virus c'est une question de jeanine
dallaire et il dit ceci la direction de
la santé publique demande l' isolement
volontaire aux citoyens qui reviennent
de l'étranger puis ça c'est l'argent
comme recommandation l'a vu tout à
l'heure
alors pourquoi ne le demandons nous pas
aux touristes qui entrent au québec
eux aussi et qui peuvent être porteurs
du coronavirus parce qu'on ne sait pas
des fois sont asymptomatiques
alors on revient la question c'est une
très bonne question parce que ça amène
des éléments peut-être d'incohérences
dans la proche comme ça mais il faut
voir fermer une frontière à la visite ça
aussi d'autres conséquences qui sont en
salle en parallèle santé et c'est évalué
en fonction du risque mais je le pauvre
d'ibm avec l'évolution sera pas une
mesure qui sera prise on a vu que
certains confirmés tous les vols vers
l'europe etc
ça va est évalué au jour le jour
actuellement on a voulu se concentrer
sur le citoyen québécois pour qui parce
que mon repos lui vous revenez qui vont
rester ici pivot pour transmettre
mais c'est sûr que je peux pour vous
dire qu'il n'ya pas aucune personne de
l'extérieur bien réussi que pourrait pas
être malade s'ils sont malades ils
prendront pas l'avion parce qu'en
théorie sont proposés par l'avion entre
l'horizon pas se poser mais ils s'y sont
rendus ici qui développent des symptômes
pour tes fans eux aussi qu'on leur donne
des consignes de de consulter pourquoi
qui transmettent la maladie partout mais
fermer la frontière où les vols sont
décision qui pourrait y seulement en
perspective de santé publique mais
d'autres choses mais c'est pas exclue
quand je vous dis mais ça serait pas
d'ottawa d'ottawa effectivement parce
que vous comprendrez que c'est des vols
internationaux et c'est ça ben moi je
pense que or moi je la majorité des
patients que j'ai vu malade avait pris
des vols malades personnes leur a
demandé aucune question donc ils sont
passés un peu comme dans une passoire et
à peu près tous les cas qui ont été
répétés répertoriés au québec sont des
cas qui sont arrivés malades ou
quasiment malades dans les jours qui ont
suivi
mais beaucoup ont été malade pendant
leur vol donc c'est clair
actuellement le système ne permet à ces
gens-là de rentrée et donc des chevaux 3
à l'intérieur de notre système
le problème souvent pour arrêter les
fermer les frontières sont une question
économique c'est à dire les gens se
posent à partir de là il soupçonne que
les gouvernements ont très peur ils ont
peur d'entraîner des cascades et de dire
à partir du moment où je ferme les
frontières il ya tout un impact
économique et de deux pertes de revenus
et caetera et il se fait de faire une
espèce d'équilibré de balance entre les
deux le problème c'est que vous dans ce
genre de situation là vous ne pouvez pas
prendre des demi mesures
à un moment donné il va falloir trancher
quelque part et il ya beaucoup de pays
qui impose à tous les gens qui arrivent
un isolement ce qui va falloir faire
attention aussi c'est qu'à un moment
donné si on ne contrôle pas notre
épidémiologie au canada on pourrait se
faire imposer comme canadiens d'être
isolés quand on va arriver ailleurs et
ça on aura absolument aucun contrôle là
dessus parce que c'est les autres pays
qui vont dire quand vous venez du canada
désolé vous êtes en isolement en à une
question de jean guy dalpé je vous la
livre à l'instinct mais on me glisse à
l'oreille qu'à l'instant à même le
premier ministre canadien s'entretient
avec le président américain donald trump
qui sans consultation de ses amis alliés
des pays alliés annoncé hier les
interdictions de vols en provenance
d'europe sauf bien sûr le royaume uni
qui sortira mais ça pose et ça a causé
tout un choc même au canada puisque on
se dit les les voyageurs vont venir au
canada pour ensuite aller aux états unis
donc je joins la question de monsieur
dalpé je crois que monsieur legault et
son équipe prennent des mesures
appropriées pour endiguer la crise
19 toutefois c'est silence radio du côté
d'ottawa quant au contrôle des
frontières et prend terrestre car on
sait encore docteur tremblay cette
hésitation du côté d'ottawa notamment
peut-être pour des raisons économiques
et que c'est pas si simple que ça mais
c'est pas si simple que ça il ya des
raisons économiques qui sont importantes
et des raisons aussi de familles qui
vont se visiter à droite puis à gauche
puisse allah des conséquences de fermer
la frontière est aussi une grande
conséquence à envisager c'est si on veut
être conséquents puis qu'on décide de
fermer les frontières à l'europe
faut le faire avec les états unis aussi
parce que le risque de plus en plus
grand que l'écho nous viennent des états
unis alors fermé la frontière canado
américaine
bonne chance je sais pas vraiment
comment on fait ça passe la frontière
elle est immense comment on fait en
sorte que ce soit respectée alors je
pense que c'est ce genre de discussion
là qu'il faut avoir pris là la question
aussi se porte où on met nos ressources
est ce qu'on veut mais énormément de
ressources à faire respecter une règle
comme celle là une fermeture de la
frontière franco où on met nos
ressources ailleurs pour empêcher la
propagation des cas le calme ans
au canada donc c'est pas quelque chose
de simple qu'il faut être sûr que la
mesure que l'on prend c'est la mesure
qui est approprié à la situation qu'on
vit présentement parce que hier vous
étiez très critique la décision de
donald trump maire de firminy l'intérim
à la frontière parce que c'était pas
reconnaître les vrais problèmes aux
états unis sa compagne en fait c'est ça
c'est que là là présentement aux états
unis oui ils ont des cas qui arrivent de
l'étranger mais leurs grands problèmes
qui sont pas capables de contrer c'est
la transmission communautaire
il ya des éclosions dans plusieurs
plusieurs régions des états unis ne sont
pas capables de le contrôler parce
qu'ils ont pas pris des mesures d'
avance il n'avait pas la capacité de
tester donc soit pas capable
d'identifier les cas donc ça se propage
dans certains villages comme une traînée
de poudre
alors la mesure affaires et tesla mesure
de fermer les frontières avec l'europe
je peux me questionner là dessus
d'autant plus qu'avec le langage qu'il
utilisait qu'il y avait une petite
composante le virus étrangers puis le
virus chinois puis tout ça est ce que
plus de préoccupations politiques de
vraies préoccupations de santé publique
dans son approche à lui alors une autre
question de valère tremblay je suis de
retour du salvador depuis hier le
gouvernement demande de me mettre en
isolement pour 14 jours pour ma
conjointe qui n'a pas fait le voyage à
ta lettre en isolement également et
quelles sont les mesures que l'on doit
prendre parce que là la mise en
isolement
ça commence aujourd'hui pour les retours
d'aujourd'hui d'accord alors que se met
par contre la personne du préoccupation
parce que je peux continuer sa conjointe
il pourrait à l'intérieur de sa maison
avoir une distanciation éviter des
contacts rapprochés mais très important
surtout défi commence à sentir le
premier simple donc d'appeler pour être
en mesure d'avoir un test
ces symptômes c'est ce sont les
symptômes de fièvre de toux et de
douleurs thoraciques ou de difficultés
respiratoires
ça commence comme un relais avec la
fièvre des douleurs un peu partout même
souche que le bouddhisme dans le fond
c'est que lui peut-être se veut pas une
certaine distance avec son épouse pour
nom mais je ne sais pas grille à blâmer
ils sont si les touches pas dans sa
maison sont en train de voir la question
sa conjointe des épaules aux banques au
plus compliqué la personne c'est une
lettre en question a donné mon bon j'ai
une amie qui revient le plus beau avec
sa famille son conjoint travaille ou
pour un ministère à québec il sera
certainement mis en quarantaine
obligatoire mon ami et en entreprise
privée pourrait elle se mettre en
quarantaine volontaire mais qu'en est il
des enfants qui fréquentent l'école
était suggéré de les mettre en
quarantaine aussi des casse têtes comme
cela c'est angoissant madame gourou mais
c'est très angoissant parce qu' un des
facteurs de protection pour pour la
santé mentale des gens dans un contexte
comme ça c'est justement de ces
l'entourage c'est à dire que c'est la
proximité des proches est ici le dilemme
c'est que souvent plusieurs scénarios
qui peuvent être envisagées
mais il faut regarder un petit peu les
risques et les bienfaits de chacun des
scénarios effectivement c'est complexe
parfois évalué donc de deux mots souvent
fauchon faut choisir le moindre
quel est votre conseil baisse à 7
personnes je vous dirais c'est une
situation qui est complexe probablement
qu'il va falloir s'assurer que c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est symptomatique
moi je vous dirais le gros défi qu'on a
eu à vivre aujourd'hui c'est les
travailleurs de la santé où là c'est un
problème majeur parce que les
travailleurs de la santé depuis qu on
les isole et depuis quand ils sont
revenus
la grosse question c'est de savoir
depuis quand vous êtes revenu et à
partir de quand vous isole c'est à dire
si vous êtes vous arrivé aujourd'hui en
vous isole si vous êtes arrivé il ya
deux jours on vous isole pas mais si
vous êtes arrivé il ya deux jours il ya
des chances que vous soyez dans votre
période d'incubation et que vous allez
être malade en quatre jours et à ce
moment là pendant ces jours là vous
allez être en contact avec un paquet de
gens qui eux risquent de devenir malade
donc sait où est ce qu'on va trancher la
ligne ça devient très complexe pour les
travailleurs de la santé et là il va
falloir trancher quelque part de façon
claire et aussi de sous gestion du
risque est ce qu'on est prêt à payer une
certaine partie si on dit à partir
d'aujourd'hui est ce que si on mettait
ça il ya ces jours on augmenterait notre
marge de sécurité où il ya 14 ans donc
c'est une question aussi de gestion de
risque et de combien on est prêt à payer
c'est un petit peu de retard à roda
écouter les bons
lui pose bien la question de taiwan et
je pense que comme on dit on à passer
d'un état antérieur en une journée de
façon extensive puisque vous disais
qu'au cours des prochains jours
il va y avoir des ajustements que des
preuves et des éléments qui vont être
prises en considération notamment
consultant les éléments opérationnels
sur le terrain parce que on a beau avoir
des principes qu'on lance on a changé à
mon avis actuellement de ton et d'
approche lots maintenant il faut noter
rationaliser et ça va se faire en lien
avec les acteurs publics ni siens mais
on le savait on va vivre ce matin quand
la décision se prenaient jeudi le
joaillier toutes les séries de questions
qu'ils allaient venir les impacts et ça
peut représenter ce je pense que cela
n'a courageux le second permet
permettait de le dire et mais je pense
maintenant qu'il faut le personnaliser
puis il faut aussi être toujours en
train d'évaluer ce qui est en train de
se passer au point de vue
d'épidémiologie mais aussi comment sais
tu sais ce que c'est déroute vécue sur
le terrain par cet objectif c'est que ça
fonctionne et donc ça fonctionne c'est
peu de dire que l'annoncé en principe
que celui de pau être capable de le
personnaliser et séduction là vont avoir
lieu à la fois avec les cliniciens à la
fois avec des autres entrepreneurs
je vous dirais les syndicats aussi ça
c'est vraiment un problème de société et
une action de société nécessaires sont
capables de pas sa femme exactement puis
moi je joue lui la le citoyen fonctions
à l'ecoute le citoyen il peut prendre
des mesures aussi les gens là même son
mais des rentes des éléments pour aider
fois d'alizée chacune des situations qui
peuvent être particulière et donc moi je
pense que maintenant on en sait le
changement de cap
puis on n'évolue pas rationaliser qu'on
voit si de répondre le plus rapidement
possible à chacune des préoccupations sa
question c'est toujours un peu dans la
main
logique son dilemme lundi le 16 mars
nous devons partir de la floride pour
une semaine nous prenons l'avion à
partir de plattsburgh vert flottera
goodale j'avoue être très indécise si
nous devons partir ou pas selon vous est
il préférable de ne pas partir je pense
qu'elle co a je connais un peu la
réponse de terrain à bouddha de tout le
monde
bah moi moi je me suis fait de poser la
question tellement de fois dans ces
derniers jours puis moi je dis
clairement si vous n'avez n'est pas
obligé d'y aller
n'y allez pas c'est difficile d'annuler
un voyage qu'on est prévu si nos belles
vacances et puis tous ceux qui on n'a
pas beaucoup d'occasions on comprend ça
c'est très difficile mais d'un autre
côté quand elle va revenir avait obligé
d'être en 41 ans la grave à cause des
recommandations du québec
donc tout à fait qu'ils sont toutes les
jolies et de leur place tout ça puis
doter les mains c'est que c'est aussi
pour la protéger dans les faits c'est un
acte social aussi pour les autres mais
aussi pour leur santé à leurs frais très
probablement aussi parce que s'il décide
de partir après l'annoncé faite par les
gouvernements ils doivent assumer la
responsabilité des conséquences de la
quarantaine j'imagine que vous lisez
quelque chose le champ oui ben non ce
que je dis aussi c'est que souvent les
compagnies d'assurance à partir du
moment où il ya ce genre de
recommandations qui vient d'organismes
ne couvre pas forcément les gens quand
ils vont en voyage et à ce moment là
s'il tombe malade dans un pays étranger
où les soins peuvent coûter très cher il
faut qu'ils soient capables aussi
d'assumer des frais qu'ils seront plus
couverts alors il ya cet aspect là il ya
l'aspect bien sûr sociale mais il savait
voyager c'est une question d'avantagés
et d'inconvénients si les inconvénients
deviennent plus problématique est plus
gros que les avantages ils ont imposé la
question c'est un petit peu y répondre
parce que le coût bénéfice est pas
toujours là n'est ce pas alors je lui
mets une questions des téléspectateurs
xavier souvent marie c concernant les
déplacements les voyages entre autres
plusieurs milliers de personnes et
québécois entre autre en floride en qui
se questionnent les snowbird s'ils
pourront revenir dans quoi trois
semaines un mois quand ils voudront le
faire
et entretemps il ya ce téléspectateur de
lévis qui les verts qui demandent
peut-on s'attendre à ce que les
déplacements soient perturbés à
l'intérieur même du pays entre les
provinces entre les territoires
par exemple dans le cas de voyage
montréal vancouver ils demandent aussi à
partir de quels critères de quel seuil
peut-on mettre des villes des régions ou
encore des provinces en confinement
quarantaine bref une question qui
suscite beaucoup de discussions c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux
le contenu des stations canadiennes y a
pas de transmission locale
au temps où on sera active conçu et fait
que pour le moment ce n'est pas le cas
mais si on ne savait toujours des gens
qui la majorité des fois c'est des gens
qui sont venus
je vous dirais de l'extérieur y ait pu
avoir un quelqu'un de la famille qui le
fait là mais sans que ce soit dans la
communauté où les jeunes ont à traiter
un avant centre d'achat des transports
en commun etc
on n'est pas dans la même poule que du
métro longueuil on n'a pas démontré
qu'un but de transmission chez ses cols
ok disons qu'ils sont on verra qu'est ce
qu'on fera ce que disait de tremblay
tantôt par rapport à la question des
villes où il est vraiment l'une
transmission ce qui se passe
actuellement par exemple en italie on
est complètement dans une autre station
met donc vous dit ça va être revu pour
jour le jour puis quel est le critère
qui oppose le nombre de corps parce que
par exemple pouvait avoir dans nos
colonnes un exemple on aurait 50 mais
qui viennent tous de l'extérieur c'est
très différent de 50 pendant une
communauté et le code ce qu'on n'a pas
entendu parler d'un cas l'hôpital
notre-dame où quelqu'un btb un isolement
qui avait du personnel qui avait été mis
en isolement mais ça vous le savez c'est
ce qu'on fait et encore peut-être que
exposé certaines personnes soit la
maison la famille ou acceptera et lorsqu
on fait ce qu'on regarde des personnes
qui auraient pu exposer
ils sont isolés s'y développent des
symptômes est bon voire des tests si de
la pratique on appelle de gestion de
corps et de contacts ça ça faisait quand
ya pas de résultats encore on peut
parler transmission locale mais s'il y
avait des résultats
au dispositif là ça deviendrait une
transmission joker on dirait que
d'ailleurs en milieu hospitalier on
parle d'une transmission nosocomiale et
long terme parce que comme transmission
de qualité ça se passe dans la
communauté mais de te revoir ce qui
travaillent en centre social hip hop
tandis que ça voudrait dire qu'il y
aurait pu avoir un genre de bris dans
les mesures de précaution et s monétaire
votre transmission oui tout à fait alors
les la transmission nosocomiale la
meilleure façon de la prévenir
c'est d'abord de bien équipée donc il ya
tout l'aspect des équipements qui est
important il ya aussi l'aspect de la
suspicion du triage des patients et
d'avoir la capacité de trier d'avoir et
de ces patients là parce que là on voit
qu'il ya une augmentation du nombre de
demandes de tests qu'on doit faire une
augmentation du nombre de patients qu'on
doit trier donc pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de transmission au québec
à l'intérieur de la communauté en
général comme pas complètement différent
de ce qui se passe déjà en colombie
britannique mais par contre il ya eu des
cas de gens qui ont été exposés dans les
hôpitaux à des gens qui étaient malades
donc il va falloir s'assurer que ces
gens là soient suivies mais juste
peut-être pour répondre vous donner un
exemple de comment ça impacte un petit
peu les choses
nous on avait notre congrès une canadien
annuel de maladies infectieuses qui
devait se tenir à vancouver au début du
mois de mai et puis le congrès n'aura
probablement pas lieu
donc vous voyez que tous les congrès
médicaux etc terrasson sont annulés
d'autant plus qu'on veut pas être tous
les infectiologues canadien pour même à
l'armement malades en même temps nous
avons généré une enfant se seraient pas
bien très bien d'ailleurs plus une
annonce très grande aujourd'hui de tous
les lieux culturels aussi qui annule
toutes les représentations
alors on poursuit cette émission
spéciale après la pause la france
l'irlande la norvège ferme nos écoles
le nombre de cas augmente partout en
europe on parle à notre collaborateur
sur place autour des tables
[Musique]
une action ça n'est pas la division qui
permettra de répondre à ce qui est
aujourd'hui une crise mondiale
l'annoncé hier soir du président trempe
on peut le dire à semer sans doute la
consternation en europe mais
certainement la colère et la frustration
alors pour peut savoir quelle est la
situation en europe et peut-être dans
d'autres pays julie est mon julie oui
mais oui avec plaisir alors on en fait
un peu un portrait je voudrais des
principaux pays les plus touchés
anne-marie on commence bien sûr avec
l'italien on ne peut passer à côté
d'importantes mesures qui ont été
annoncées aujourd'hui déjà ces images
qui ont fait le tour de la terre depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant voire
plusieurs semaines des villes
complètement des heures des places
publiques
justement déserté 12 pays qui avaient
été mises en quarantaine on est rendu à
15000 cam il meurt en tout c'est une
hausse de plus de 20% si on compare il
ya 24 heures à peine donc c'est énorme
en termes de victimes en italie ne paye
est en quarantaine au complet tous les
commerces sont fermés hormis bien sûr
les pharmacies et les épiceries mais
tous les autres commerces les lieux
publics les écoles et on a même annoncé
des mesures particulières du côté du
vatican
toutes les églises catholiques sont
fermés c'est une première dans
l'histoire moderne et le pape a lui même
ordonné données en fait de
l'autorisation de manquer la messe du
dimanche et vous dire et surtout dans un
pays aussi catholique aussi pratiquant
que l'italie s'est pas séparé
effectivement en france maintenant là
aussi près de 3000 cas maintenant 61
morts macron demande aux gens les plus
vulnérables aux personnes de 70 ans et
plus dit il de rester à la maison en
royans au royaume-uni maintenant près de
600 cas confirmés à l'heure actuelle une
dizaine de morts on s'attend ce que ça
empire selon ce qu'a dit boris johnson
aujourd'hui en point de presse il a
ajouté que c'était la pire crise
sanitaire de sa génération en espagne
maintenant quatre localités de la
catalogne ont été et placées sous
confinement aujourd'hui pendant ce temps
les églises les écoles pardonnez-moi
sont fermées dans la région de madrid et
je termine avec la norvège rapidement
700 cas dont un mort
les écoles fermer tous les commerçants
faits sont fermées sauf bien sûr les
épiceries les pharmacies ont nécessité
oblige et on annonçait que les exercices
de l'otan était suspendu je termine en
vous disant que pour les gens la maison
qui souhaiteraient nous envoyer leurs
commentaires leurs réactions et bien sûr
leurs questions voici les moyens de le
faire surtout été le mot clic 24,60
l'adresse courriel comme d'habitude et
aussi sur la page facebook de radio
canada
merci à julie à tout à l'heure et on
vient d'apprendre que la tchéquie la
slovaquie ont choisi de fermer leurs
frontières justement pour limiter la
propagation du virus
quelle est la situation vraiment le
climat qui règne en ce moment en europe
le jouer à vous seul un grand
spécialiste de la question européenne
jean quatremer bonsoir jean quatremer
merci d'être avec nous à cette heure
tardive
on le disait tout à l'heure la décision
d'autres hommes passent mais
certainement la colère et la frustration
en europe la spa sur les gens ont été
étonnés ici et ailleurs charles michel
et président du conseil européen des
chefs des gouvernements et our souls un
soderling qui est la présidente de la
commission ont dit qu'ils avaient été
pris par surprise
ils ont découvert l'annnonce de trump il
a évité de soigneusement de consulter
les européens
son argument ça a été de dire ça aurait
pris beaucoup trop de temps les
consulter alors qu'en l'occurrence on a
quand même des responsables qui sont
identifiés lignes européennes désormais
au moins deux numéros de téléphone c'est
pas très compliqué fait avertir ses
partenaires européens mais manifestement
trump décidé d'ajouter la crise à la
crise et d'étendre la panique
un petit peu se réalise quand même qui
règne dans le dans le monde depuis
l'apparition du cornât virus et surtout
qu'il parle d'un virus étrangers et
reproche à l'europe de ne pas avoir pris
ses responsabilités évidemment envisage
peut-être chacun des pays qu en est il
vraiment en europe et si possible
quelques pays de la capacité ou non de
freiner la propagation du virus il
pressent dans macro qui a parlé ce soir
à la nation pour annoncer aussi de
nouvelles mesures absolument mais
d'abord il faut dire que les américains
sont ont il est gonflé ça comme ça parce
que corinne virus est déjà chez eux et
on voit que depuis les débuts de cette
crise les frontières ne servent
strictement à rien et si les frontières
avait servi à quelque chose
par exemple en 1918 un moment où le
monde était séparé et les bancaires on
n'aurait pas eu la grippe espagnole ça
n'a strictement rien n'empêchait là je
crois que c'est une façon pour lui de
rebondir parce qu'il a sous-estimé
l'ampleur de la crise n'emporte
l'ampleur surtout des craintes
des opinions publiques et aujourd'hui il
fait porter la faute d'abord sur les
chinois ils tentèrent commercial avec la
chine est maintenant sur les européens
ils étaient six en guerre commerciale
avec les européens et du caresse son
électorat dans le sens du poil
expliquant à quel point sa luge
étrangers mais attention en europe c'est
exactement la même chose
vous l'avez dit vous-même en slovaquie
et en république tchèque on vient de
fermer les frontières il ya des
contrôles la frontière ans italiennes
entre l'italie et la france
a vintimille et fermer ce soit en
allemagne entre la frontière par la
france et l'allemagne
il ya des contrôles de température qui
sont prises le tout les pales pour tous
les toutes les voitures et donc le
résultat c'est que vous avez des heures
et des heures d'embouteillages aux
frontières donc c'est une panique
absolument généralisée et le côté s'est
affairé à dire us étrangers et donc on
va le stopper en interdisant à un pays à
tout 30 tout liaisons internationales
c'est du grand n'importe quoi encore une
fois si on pouvait arrêter quoi que ce
soit en fermant sa frontière
ça se saurait bien qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à arrêter quoi que ce soit mais
la panique et maman général je dirais
que le trump ont pendant cette décision
de l'est avant un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière puisque les européens depuis
ce matin prennent des décisions dans
tous les sens la commission l'a par
exemple bienheureux vient de faire
publier un petit recueil de tous les
deux toutes les décisions qui ont été
prises dans les 27 pays de l'union
européenne mais parce qu'ils sont aussi
diverses que variées
mais tout cela se traduise en quelques
mots par un enfermement nationale
quelque part pour le move l'europe
cherche à sortir du monde comme les
états unis cherchent à sortir du monde
et je crois qu'il ya une semaine une
macro on l'a très bien dit quand il a
expliqué que aujourd'hui on entré dans
une ère de démondialisation
on est en même temps il ya cette
capacité des systèmes de santé en europe
de gérer la situation on a
lui on a entendu qu'en italie notamment
on devait choisir entre brancher un
appareil respiratoire sur une personne
âgée ou une personne plus jeune dans
l'espagne c'est l'état d'urgence
j'espère que la situation en france mais
est ce que au niveau de l'europe on est
capable de prendre des mesures
communautaires pour venir en aide à ces
populations et soutenir les systèmes de
santé qui connaîtraient des faiblesses
c'est une très bonne question parce que
la commission européenne
l'exécutif européen a tardé à prendre la
mesure de la crise il n'a pas proposé un
plan d'ensemble
la plan d'action aux citoyens européens
et aux gouvernements européens
il explique en disant parce que la santé
n'est pas une compétence communautaire
la santé c'est la compétence des états
qui composent l'union européenne la
commission en tant que tel mais peu
juste appuyer l'action des états donc
elle a laissé la panique s'installe et
marne il a fallu que mardi dernier
la france exige la réunion d'un conseil
européen des chefs d'état de
gouvernement donc les 27
j'ai terriblement qui sort est leader
par visioconférence à paris nantes
l'heure n'est plus aux grandes
rencontres entre embrassades et aux
grandes poignées de main pour que là on
était un début de semblant de
coordination qui a volé en éclats
aujourd'hui mais c'est très compliqué de
se mettre d'accord sur des mesures de
santé encore une fois parce que comme
vous le dites les systèmes de santé sont
très divers en plus il dépend donc les
états et les états se sont responsables
de la santé de la population d'où toutes
ses maîtresses de florilège de mesures
de feu d'artifice de mesures aussi
diverses que variées d'un état à l'autre
alors on essaye de se coordonner mais
c'est long parce que on est obligé de le
faire en pleine crise intérieure il
fallait commencer quelque alamo et demi
il a essayé de se mettre d'accord on est
on a été pris par surprise
exactement comme en 2015 vous vous
rappelez au moment de la crise des
migrants et des réfugiés
lorsqu'un lyon 2
j'ai syriens s'étaient rués en grèce et
soir des balkans et ont finalement être
accueillis en allemagne une
l'immigration n'était pas une compétence
européenne
elle l'est devenue par la force des
choses et des larges alors essayé
d'inventer un traitement commun si vous
voulez du traitement comme anne krystel
une dernière question rapidement géant
quatremer est ce qu'on comprend l'europe
l'exception faite par donald trump
quant au royaume uni son grand ami et
août johnson a dit aujourd'hui qui était
la pire crise presque de l'espoir alors
la pire crise quand même pas exagérer je
rappelle quand même
mille morts pour l'instant en italie et
la moyenne d'âge et 81,4 ans donc faut
pas exagérer il ya 4000 morts sur les
routes par an en italie
à titre de comparaison en france par
exemple chaque année la grippe
saisonnière fait dix mille morts bon
dans tout ça pour ramener un petit peu
quand même un peu de un peu de calme
est ce qu'on comprend l'exception
souhaiter aux produits évidemment pas il
n'y a pas que le royaume uni vous
oubliez le site et l'irlande qui n'est
pas non plus un peu mal américain et
c'est intéressant ça quelque part
comme si le monde anglo saxon été
immunisés il ya une sorte d'immunité
anglophones en rédigeant le sol c'était
non c'est totalement mais
incompréhensible et en voilà ce que vise
à nouveau
donald trump s'est véritablement
d'enfoncer un coin entre les européens
il déteste union européenne il voit dans
cette crise l'occasion justement de
diviser divisé on urine
merci jean quatremer depuis bruxelles et
par là de donald trump de la gestion de
la crise aux etats unis
je joins didier fassin anthropologue
médecins professeurs de sciences
sociales l'institute for advanced study
de princeton et titulaire de la chaire
de santé publique au collège de france
d'interface un merci d'être avec nous
vous parlez en aux téléspectateurs ainsi
à des collègues de santé publique et
microbiologiste sur notre plateau ce
soir mais dit tout ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis vous venez d'entendre un
collègue européen critiqué la décision
de crainte qualité vous votre réaction
face à l'annoncé hier de donald g de
fermer les frontières à l'europe
je crois que c'est une c'est une
décision qui est d'abord absurdes comme
vient de l'évoquer puisque on laisse
entrer les citoyens de grande bretagne
mais on ferme la porte aux polonais
alors que il ya dix fois plus de cas
dans le premier pays que dans le second
mais surtout c'est une mesure qui est
épidémiologiquement inefficace puisque
elle cherche à faire croire que le virus
et étrangers comme le dit le président
lui-même
alors qu'aujourd'hui le problème aux
états unis est avant tout un problème de
contamination communautaire c'est à dire
des gens qui dans leurs quartiers dans
leur environnement dans leurs réunions
vont se s'exposer à d'autres personnes
qui sont eux-mêmes que affecté par par
le corps d'un virus sans avoir voyagé
sans avoir brillé j'ai alors et puis
troisièmement c'est une
c'est une décision qui est politiquement
motivée de la manière la plus la plus
déplaisante puisque c'est une mesure qui
tira qui est qu un arrière-fond et
xénophobe
aujourd'hui même sur le site web de la
maison blanche était affiché un article
qui disait que les politiques de lutte
contre l'immigration menée par le
gouvernement et le président avaient
permis d'éviter l'arrivée sur le
territoire des etats-unis de 150000
personnes infectées par la route
donc on voit comment il s'agit là de
quelques d'une mesure qui est encore une
fois absurde inefficace et démagogique
est ce qu'à fait quel est votre plus
grande crainte à ce moment ci quant à la
propagation de la de lakovic 19 ans
qu'on a beaucoup parlé depuis quelques
semaines déjà des faiblesses du système
de l' incapacité à détecter à faire
passer subir les tests là où il le
fallait
on a muselé des médecins notamment dans
l'état de washington je pense à cette
docteur juke avait repéré ce coronavirus
c'était silence radio du côté de la cdc
et de laives des as
est-ce qu'on peut encore faire confiance
et que les enfants votre plus grande
crainte face à la gestion de l'épidémie
en ce moment la pandémie parce qu'on
peut dire c'est qu'effectivement la le
dépistage août est tout simplement des
personnes suspectées de ducobu 19 marche
très très mal il ya moins d'une semaine
on comptait à peine 5000 tests qui
avaient été réalisées c'était sept cent
fois moins
rapporté à la population 720 que la
corée du sud
donc on est là dans un dans un
dispositif où on ne teste pas ce qui
fait qu'on peut dire aussi qu évidemment
on a peu de cas peu de cas il ya quand
même
1600 un peu plus de 1600 cas aujourd'hui
qui ont été que qui sont reconnus mais
on voit bien que cette ce ce déni qui
s'associe avec un déficit de testing est
bien conduit à minimiser la réalité de
l'épidémie et donc à rendre le travail
de la santé publique bien plus bien plus
utile cela s'ajoute à cela non plus au
niveau de la santé publique mais au
niveau des hôpitaux au niveau de la
prise en charge des malades quelque
chose qu'on connaît bien aux états unis
à savoir les très grandes inégalités qui
lie à face à l'accès aux soins le fait
que 87 millions de personnes aux états
unis sont peu ou mal assurés dont 20
millions ne le sont pas du tout ce qui
veut dire que ce sont des gens qui ne
vont pas se faire soigner un certain
nombre parmi eux on estime à 11 millions
environ sont des personnes qui sont en
situation irrégulière mais souvent sur
le territoire depuis très longtemps et
qui auront les plus grandes réticences à
aller à l'hôpital
lorsqu'ils seront lorsqu'ils seront
malades
ou à se faire tester et donc on a là
toute une série de toute une série
d'éléments sans compter le fait que dans
un pays où il y à 38 millions de
travailleurs qui sont au dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
et ça ne concerne sur dur est pas
seulement cela les gens préfèrent
continuer à travailler même s'ils sont
malades plutôt que de perdre des
journées de rémunération sachant qu'il
n'y a pas deux il ya passe comme seconde
et des systèmes de protection comme on
peut avoir en europe
probablement aussi au canada pour une
personne qui sont qui sont obligés de
ceux de se mettre au repos pour une
raison de maladie dont on a là on a là
un ensemble à la fois au niveau de la
santé publique et donc de la prévention
et de la médecine et donc de la prise en
charge
on a une situation qui est qui est
assurément préoccupante et je dirais
d'autant plus préoccupante que le
gouvernement ne veut pas l'affronter
ouais il clamait seule crainte est
toujours dans le déni qu'il n'ya qu'à 32
morts alors qu'anne avait déjà 38 ce
matin moment il a pris la parole la
docteure fasse un merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté de nous parler ce soir je suis
persuadé qu'on pourra se reparler ce que
vous le voulez bien dans les prochaines
heures sinon prochains jours merci
beaucoup de coeur face à merci à vous au
revoir
[Musique]
les 20h01 bonsoir bienvenue à cette
deuxième heure de notre émission
spéciale question de coronavirus
l'émission grand reportage personnalités
dany turcotte l'urgence de vivre sera
diffusé à une date ultérieure a confirmé
à l'heure au cours de la prochaine heure
nos experts vont répondre à d'autres
questions que vous nous avez fait
parvenir aussi beaucoup de fausses
nouvelles circulent sur la copie de 19
comment séparer le vrai du faux
il n'y a toujours pas de directives de
québec concernant les écoles mais de
plus en plus de commissions scolaires
prennent elles mêmes la décision c'est
ce qu'on apprend maintenant ces
commissions scolaires seront fermés
demain je voulais nomme marie victorin
riverside des patriotes des pâquerettes
bourgeois des hautes rivières trois lacs
chemin du roy du pays-des-bleuets de
l'or-et-des-bois de saint-hyacinthe
également l'université du québec à
chicoutimi déjà l'université de montréal
avait fait parvenir des consignes cet
après midi
l'université laval quant à elle reste
ouverte
alors on poursuit cette deuxième avec
les invités karl weiss de christine
brouh vadam tremblay et dr arruda
réaction à cette annonce et comme son
scolaire de claude haget vous saviez
peut-être pouvoir seulement dans le
contexte de risque ce qu'ont annoncé
aujourd'hui certains notamment la
question des rassemblements etc
le contexte des gens qui reviennent je
dirais deux semaines de relâche on
certaine les gens qui ont des sites est
actuellement de fermer et on va
réévaluer sa notamment demain avec le
ministère
de l'éducation puis avec du melon aux
préliminaires sur les modalités est ce
que cela pourrait s'étendre aux
garderies et aux universités je dois
tout est possible j'ai quand même joué
le soutage de jeu qu'on vous dire parce
que parce que ça va dépendre de la
situation mais pour voir que la question
des commissions scolaires et aussi l
chaud tout absolument ceci ou retour de
la semaine de relâche et ayant appris
que des sels de 250 personnes que
c'était peut-être que son énergie ce
ticket aussi je pense a dans la prise en
compte de la crème de certains parents
katherine et je pense que l'air devant
le fait de se tenir à cette journée ont
décidé de fermer mais revault révèle 800
courant de la semaine
très bien alors on va aller quand même
aux questions du public jérémy michelot
nous fait parvenir cette question quels
sont les risques de transmission du
virus dans une école secondaire
d'environ 2000 élèves
est-ce que je devrais m'inquiéter du
fait du manque d'hygiène dans l'école
dans les toilettes il ya deux
distributeurs de savon pour qu'un levier
la plupart du temps ils sont à moitié
vides je m'agite sur cette partie
d'évaluation tout à fait vivre et y
avoir de consignes de newcom son
scolaire premièrement même par rapport
aux cafétérias de détaler les dîners de
changer l'usiné puis comme je vous dis
tout va dépendre des transmissions qu'on
va avoir l'honneur pas encore de local
mais dès maintenant il va y avoir des
consignes par an par à l'hygiène comme
tel on peut devoir augmenter les
périodes telles distances et les dîners
quand je vous dis donc il serait dur est
combien temps fermeture des écoles
idéalement 14 jours 30 jours parce que
les voyages ces 30 jours ça va dépendre
la situation tant que des transmissions
je dire locales actives
je veux dire on peut l'affirmer mais fou
à leur temps qu'un dakar est des
transfusions ça pourrait être amendé
semaine et ça va dépendre évidemment de
la situation au québec ce qu'il faut pas
oublier quand on ferme les écoles c'est
que souvent les parents vont rester à la
maison et ça ça peut avoir un impact
très important sur la force de travail
nous dans le réseau de la santé imaginez
vous
si beaucoup d'infirmières et
d'inhalothérapeutes de personnel de
santé c'est déjà arrivé je vous le dis
ça commence et elle est technicienne de
laboratoire ne rendent pas travailler
parce que les enfants sont à la maison
à ce moment là ça a un impact sur notre
capacité à répondre
c'est ça le problème c'est que l'on peut
organiser alors qu'est ce qu'on fait et
ce qu'on organise des des écoles
garderies dans les hôpitaux pour pouvoir
permettre à ces gens là mais d'un autre
côté en faisant ça rappelez vous les
enfants sont des vecteurs d'infection
alors il ya toutes sortes de questions
qu'il faut se poser et je vous dis aussi
quelque part à un moment donné quand
c'est tellement circulant dans la
communauté
ça peut devenir une mesure qui pour qui
est que plus de contraintes moindres que
de bénéfices les autres de fermer les
écoles de contrat oui si jamais un mot
nuit tellement de transmission par tous
ok ouais puis copie mais en plus ce
qu'on démontre c'est en ce moment le
milieu scolaire qui est amplificateur du
virus de fermer les écoles puis de de
créer tous les problèmes aux parents
avec 7 euros ça peut devenir un problème
a prêté des quads en défense initiale
comme tel mais est toujours plusieurs
facteurs à garder dans ses éléments à
l'eau mais vous comprenez vous c'est sûr
que le jour où x mais c'est comme des
les candidats circulation partout qu'on
ne entre guillemets perdu un peu le
contrôle est de maintenir deux d'arrêter
d'aider des activités qui sont
essentielles qui ont des impacts comme
le digne de travail sur le personnel sur
les parents sur des familles mais sa foi
river lui qui serait mieux d'être à
l'école parce que le risque est faible
la gravité est faible c'est ça mon pays
riches oui pays explique dans les fêtes
en les ramenant à les sortir des cônes
en plus envie d'en diminuer encore de
transmission y avoir des transmissions
ok là encore vous en éthique clinique en
fait on dit souvent des fois le mieux
est l'ennemi du bien puisque c'est ce
que j'appelle l'examen des scénarios que
les gens doivent faire effectivement
pour anticiper les conséquences des
actions est ce que je voulais dire
surtout c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya
des mesures comme ça les fait c'est
d'augmenter l'inquiétude de la
population alors que faudrait quand même
que la population comprenne que c'est
rassurant
sûr que quand une décision comme telle
mais c'est paradoxal quand une décision
comme ça qu'ils se prennent
c'est la prudence à noël ça donne une
impression subjective que aujourd'hui la
situation est infiniment plus grave qu
hier alors que il ya une décision qui
s'est prise qui est une qui est une
décision protectrice préventive et
protectrice de la population mais juste
dire aux gens que ça fait l'effet
paradoxal mais qu'il faut quand même
comprendre que dans le fond est un
ensemble de mesures de protection qui
sont mises en place
la nouvelle est inquiétante mais mais il
reste que c'est une nouvelle protectrice
aime dire les mots là-dessus à la main
en fait l'un des problèmes à prendre ce
type de décision là c'est con il ya des
inconnues
c'est qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne
connaît pas par exemple par rapport à ce
virus en particulier on sait pas quel
rôle les enfants jouent comme vecteurs
ou transmetteur du suffixe particulier
par rapport à d'autres épidémies
on savait avec un plus haut à castres à
ce que les enfants pour être très malin
de grosses maladie pis donc ils
deviennent des vecteurs importants dans
ce cas ci on ignore encore de ces
éléments loeb ça aide pas à prendre
l'addition alors on va aller à une brève
pause les messieurs puis on se retrouve
tout de suite après
[Musique]
l'émission spéciale question de
coronavirus se poursuit jusqu'à 21h on
en parlait brièvement après la pause
même s'il n'ya toujours pas de
directives de québec concernant les
écoles le docteur horacio arruda nous
disait que la question serait examinée
au cours des prochaines heures comme
tout est réexaminé d'heure en heure de
jour en jour mais sachez que dès ce soir
et comme son scolaires prennent la
décision de fermer leurs portes dès
demain je voulais nomme marie victorin
riverside des hautes rivières trois lacs
chemin du roy du pays-des-bleuets
marie-victorin de l'or et les bois de
saint-hyacinthe et des collèges privés
aussi ont annoncé leur fermeture alors
j'imagine que les les personnes
intéressées ont déjà été informés de la
chose et notre collègue thomas germé
gerbet a tourné des images au maxi de
saint michel à montréal et où on
prévient les clients lampre qui lie à 2
heures d'attentes aux caisses
la plupart entre quand même alors julie
oui mais on voit avec ces images jeanne
mas rien que
viacom pas dire comment qualifier les
derniers jours rend les gens qui se
ruent sur plusieurs magasins des
magasins grande surface des marchés
d'alimentation pour aller faire des
provisions
donc c'est ce qu'on a remarqué beaucoup
ces derniers jours qu'ils veulent aller
faire justement d accumuler des
quantités importantes de denrées non
périssables ou encore de papier toilette
disons le c'est ce qu'on a vu ces
derniers jours ont aussi beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux
et là il ya des questions qui vont dans
ce sens dans le sens du moins des
épiceries des lieux publics on continue
de fréquenter malgré justement cette
interdiction des événements de plus
grande ampleur
deux questions en ce sens la première la
voix si céline bouchard qui nous dit
cela l'épicerie les paniers sur
roulettes et même les autres paniers à
main sont de véritables vecteurs de
transmission du virus y at il des
mesures à prendre pour éviter une
contamination quand on se présente dans
un marché d'alimentation
une autre question qui va un peu dans le
même sens de véronique ronde chéreau qui
nous demandent comment se comporte le
virus sur des surfaces inerte par
exemple sur le pain chez le boulanger
sur les fruits et légumes sur les autres
aliments qu'on a un corps peut retrouver
dans les magasins elle de vente peut-on
manger ces aliments aussitôt acheté et
surtout elle rajoute est-ce que la
congélation suit le virus très bonne
question et je termine avec quelques
petites pistes en vrac
parce qu'on reçoit des centaines de
questions pour pas dire des milliers
depuis le début de l'émission c'est vrai
j'ai jamais vu ça
quelques-unes en vrac on nous demande
ces femmes enceintes sont plus
vulnérables que par exemple une autre
femme du même âge qui ne porterait pas
d'enfant est ce que le foetus peut être
atteint les animaux sont ils des
vecteurs de contamination peuvent-ils
être contagieux et beaucoup de personnes
s'interrogent du fait que les casinos
demeurent ouverts marie donc plusieurs
commentaires en ce sens je vous redonne
la parole et je vous reviens peu plus
tard avec d'autres questions dont on
peut regarder les tableaux pas loin non
il ya beaucoup de questions la banque
qui se lance on va les partager vous
allez les russes sur les surfaces
inertes comme sur les paniers ou quoi
que ce soit les coronavirus sont des
virus qui peuvent persister sur des
surfaces inerte pendant de quelques
heures à quelques jours donc ils peuvent
rester loeb ça va dépendre de si la
surface elle est humide ou si elle est
sèche
donc c'est une bonne idée c'est pour ça
qu'on recommande aux jeunes
désinfecter les surfaces sur lesquelles
ils préparent leur nourriture et de se
laver les mains régulièrement
après avoir caché un panier par exemple
de provisions c'est une très bonne chose
de se laver les mains mais mais ceci dit
c'est un virus qui est très facile à
détruire parce que c'est un virus avec
une enveloppe donc avec les produits de
nettoyage habituel c'est un virus qui va
être facilement éliminé oui sur la
nourriture on pense pas que c'est un
problème il n'y a pas de bottes
d'évidence de transmission on appelle
fécale orale en mangeant de ce virus là
ça a été regardé en chine dans les
huiles le plus de cas possible on pense
pas que c'est un problème de toute façon
on va toujours recommandé aux gens de la
vie leurs fruits leurs légumes alors ça
devrait être suffisant pour s'en
débarrasser autre question les femmes
enceintes les plus gros tels plus
vulnérables alors si on regarde le virus
le corps les coronavirus habituellement
sont pas tératogènes c'est à dire c'est
pas des risques sont connus pour donner
des malformations mais par contre la
fièvre on sait que la fièvre c'est
jamais bon quand on est enceinte
donc premièrement donc si vous avez
attrapé le coronavirus et vous êtes
enceinte le fait de tomber malade avoir
de la fièvre
ça peut être problématique la deuxième
chose qui est important de souligner
c'est que les femmes enceintes ont
habituellement la grossesse un état
unitaire un petit peu diminué et on la
vit avec l'influenza l'influenza est
beaucoup plus sévère chez les femmes
enceintes que chez les femmes en bonne
santé du même âge et même si elles sont
enceintes et en bonne santé
donc on n'a pas beaucoup de données
actuellement chez les femmes enceintes
du coronavirus mais c'est sûr qu'il va
falloir avoir accumulé des données et
évidemment les femmes enceintes il faut
les protéger éventuellement la journée
où on aurait un vaccin efficace qu'on
pourra donner aux femmes enceintes ça
devra être un groupe prioritaire en
attendant qu'elle conseille alors en
attendant il faut évidemment leur donner
les conseils généraux d'être de ceux de
faire attention c'est sûr que souvent le
problème c'est que quand elles sont
enceintes elles ont peut-être déjà
d'autres enfants en bas âge autour
d'elle qui aussi peuvent être des
vecteurs de contamination
donc il faut faire encore plus attention
donc c'est un ensemble de mesures qu'il
va falloir faire chez les femmes
enceintes
c'est sûr que les voyages chez les
femmes enceintes c'est vraiment pas le
meilleur moment dans le contexte actuel
alors c'est vraiment les mesures
générales puis lesquelles les animaux
ben non à date faut pas trop s'inquiéter
lahti
les casinos restent ouverts dr arruda
m'écouter c'est tard comme vous évaluez
oui c'est un peu comme enjeu prêts à
vous de faire ça je vois qu'ils
appliquent de la distanciation des
mesures d'augmentation des 250 personnes
6 à 2,6 à wattrelos
bon moi je vais vous dire on a fait
l'annoncé aujourd'hui
là ça ramène toute une série de
questions ça fait partie des choses
quand vous arrivez le ring comme tels
parce que depuis le site actuellement il
n'y a pas de transmission locale
le cerveau de ce sera peut-être un
élément facteur de transmission locale
au moins que la clientèle soit toute la
clientèle de l'extérieur du pays juste à
regarder juste des éléments convoquons
votre analyse et notamment avec nos
partenaires de 2,2 le tri de loterie de
loto-québec temps et c'est toute la
machine parce que cette nouvelle
approche
elle implique l époque et des gens mais
encore plus maintenant différent et les
machines à sous
ça doit être pas mal ça c'est moi je
vous le dire puisque je pense que le
médecin chez we fall et désinfecter avec
cette erreur mais il faut pas se fier
sur les autres on n'est jamais aussi
bien servi que par soi même
lavez vous les mains ce que je pense que
votre lavabo à côté du désinfectant
madame roux sur les images de mon
collègue thomas gerbet cette inquiétude
cette panique deuxième en attendant un
maxi on m'a rapporté dans un léger à
saint lambert des tablettes est visible
jusqu'au dépôt la situation ailleurs
mais qu'est-ce que ça génère quels
conseils donnez vous ayez eu deux sites
de penser en fait que les gens vont
avoir quand il ya des annonces comme ça
il va y avoir des pensées constructive
puis il va y avoir des pensées qui sont
un petit peu parasitaire les pensées
parasites r c'est celle qui tourne en
boucle c'est les ruminations c'est celle
qui nous rendent un puissant qui nous
inquiète énormément les pensée
constructive c'est celle qui nous font
prendre action
alors donc c'est un comportement qui
fait juste faire en sorte que les gens
ont l'impression de prendre action et
d'avoir du contrôle sur une situation
s'était pas nécessairement
toujours le meilleur facteur de
protection mais à tout le moins c'est
une action qui permet aux gens de se
rassurer
bon très bien alors on va aller à une
pause au moment de remettre des mesures
annoncées par via rail je vais lire le
texte je vous en parlerai après la pause
et puis au retour j'aimerais que l'on
parle de la capacité de dépister ce
fameux 8h20 on a parlé à deux
difficultés des deux heures d'attentes
avoir la ligne
est ce que d'autres façons envisagée
pour détecter dépister le virus on va en
parler au retour de la pause
alors reste avec mon ami philippe sion
se poursuit dans un esprit
[Musique]
question de carabine et se poursuit avec
tout une question de marie tôle de
chaillé je voulais lit elle est
enseignante au secondaire depuis lundi
c'est le retour de la relâche scolaire
je suis présentement grippé depuis mardi
comme enseignante je me considère au
premier relais nous manipulons bien les
objets durant la journée avec aux élèves
évidemment les cahiers crayons etc de ce
ne sont vraiment pas exempt de saleté et
ou de microbes et ou de virus comme si
le retour de relâche certains
enseignants ont voyagé ces représentait
la croisière plusieurs ont pris l'avion
quant aux élèves ils sont plus de 1000
élèves chez nous mais je dis combien ont
voyagé avec leurs parents hier devant
les symptômes j'ai appelé le 9 heures
une heure 30 d'attenté ningbo buteur on
m'a demandé si j'avais voyagé récemment
non est-ce que j'ai plus de transports
en commun stib les par l'inde est
caduque avec 19 noms j'étais en contact
avec une personne qui a voyagé dans un
pays à risque aucune idée au vu de mes
réponses il n'y a pas lieu de me tester
pour lakovic 19
j'ai sûrement une grippe saisonnière je
trouve l'équation un peu simple je suis
incapable d'évaluer les risques qui
m'entourent alors de terreur là c'est ça
peut-être la difficulté en ce moment
c'est que les gens ont peur imagine
qu'ils sont porteurs s'ils ont un
symptôme de re met tout ça et sont
presque au but de s'auto diagnostiquer
pour appeler lever tard puis ça prend
deux heures d'attenté le ccc
c'est inacceptable par de simples vous
dire que c'est parce qu'on vise comme
système faut dire qu'avec le non-soutien
actuellement et des gens qui sont pas
malades qu'on peu de symptômes qu'ils
appellent le butin ce clic ce qui ce qui
entraîne des problèmes mais de toute
façon faut avoir une plus grande
capacité de faire des choses ça c'est
clair on ville met en place des
cliniques tout récemment à ce moment ci
comment voulez pas que ça devienne une
clinique pour la grée pour les autres
infections comme ça circule pas on est
passé à travers de huit ans mais tout ça
va être réévalué d'une nouvelle ligne
qui est là pour donner mon retour à
l'écran la demande aux gens qui veulent
avoir des informations trop parce qu'ils
ont des symptômes d'appeler cette ligne
nous si jamais les gens cette ligne sans
concours du cinquantenaire est ce que ça
marche bien
n'auraient pas encore 24 heures ok moi
ce que je tenterai de vous dire de sécu
puis à la limite quand les cliniques
sont connus puis qu'on veut être en
circulation de corona virus au québec
mais ce moment là on pourra avoir plus
de tissus du peut-être donné un accident
à ceux qui l' une des courses
l'association expliquant la chose son
croît être porteurs du virus
on appelle le bêta il faut être patient
ça marche pas toujours
il ya que la montérégie québec et
montréal qu'est ce qu'on fait si on est
en gaspésie en beauce et montmagny si
j'appuie de 6 à plus de 8 en gaspésie ou
en bourse puisque chic et de la
centralisation mais de toute façon ce
que je vais vous dire on va augmenter
les effectifs au butin on va s'assurer
de donner une meilleure réponse qu'on
veut réévaluer à mon avis le système
system par le 8 en est trop longue les
gens pacsés a été alors qu'ils devraient
être testés on va y arriver lui
on m'informe à l'instant que québec a
mis fin à la saison du hockey mineur au
québec commis fin à la saison du hockey
mineur sur le coeur
une prudence élémentaire mais étant
donné que toutes les ligues majeures on
me fait alors saison je pense que c'est
très logique
alors revenons la capacité de détester
parce qu'on a vu qu'aux états unis a
tellement de barrières des critères ici
le critère c'est géant symptômes je
pense pour débutants 1
mais là je peux l'être lennik donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas éliminer le plus
de barrières possible pour le dépistage
vous dites hybrides tout à fait nous ça
fait très longtemps qu'on a déjà de
pousser les gens gouvernement à mettre
les tests en place et à les délocaliser
au niveau 2 des centres hospitaliers
alors ça prend plusieurs semaines avant
d'arriver là donc il fallait il ya trois
quatre semaines commencé à dire il faut
plus de tests faut augmenter notre
capacité
il faut aussi ne pas avoir tous les
tests à une place parce que si un
problème à cette place là vous vous
imaginez les conséquences pour le
système donc le test c'est le seul outil
actuellement pour gérer cette éclosion
après ça de faciliter les tests dans
c'était d'avoir la première ligne la
première ligne n'était pas prête
si vous alliez dans une clinique il ya
une semaine et encore aujourd'hui les
médecins de famille sont inquiets vin
qui est démuni par rapport à tout ça
donc c'est clair que la première ligne
n'était pas prêt même en médecine
spécialisée
il ya des médecins spécialistes qui sont
leur propre clinique et qui était pas
prêt imaginez vous allez voir votre
obstétricienne gynécologue
dans sa clinique et vous êtes malade il
n'y avait pas de protocole qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec le losc en allemand
alors que ça s'améliore je dirais nous
on a poussé pour que ça s'améliore
rapidement
je pense que la mise en place des
cliniques est un très bon point il ya
toute une organisation logistique a
arrangés qui va devoir se faire
rapidement
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire sur
les réelles sur les régions à nouveau
les faits actuellement
selon l'organisation de services chacune
des des présidents est en général va
s'organiser pour qu'ils identifient un
endroit
claus is used à travers le québec ils
vont identifier dans le rouge sa
dévotion des tests oui et puis si vous
me permettez je drague d'autorité c'est
ça aussi on est à évaluer effectivement
d'un transfert de postes l'endroit mais
il ça va être très important surtout
quand on voir à tester beaucoup d'autres
séries davance vous avez dit que c'était
loin déterminé que ça ne faisait que
commencer et fait que ça on va être
confronté à des milliers de témoins et
puis l'on parle pas en terme de semaines
je pense assez urgent qu'on arrive à
cette décentralisation parce que on voit
que le nombre de tests doit augmenter
présentement il ya que le laboratoire de
santé publique du québec qui fait qu'ils
font tous les tests au québec
et puis ils travaillent sont des anges
il travaille extrêmement bien et c'est
eux qui ont développé le test puis ils
sont en train de valider avec d'autres
experts la façon de décentraliser pour
qu'on les hôpitaux puissent avoir des
tests mais souhaite c'est urgent en fait
c'est ça devrait être une priorité ça va
savoir combien de temps son étude le
plus rapidement possible ce que je peux
vous dire que je ne peux m'engager dans
un chiffre sans avoir mal d des chances
mais il faut aussi comprendre que le on
a eu la séquence autour de deux
premières semaines de janvier il fallu
développer le test validé le laboratoire
parce qu'il faut pas que les gens
pensent qu' on est automatiquement
l'était ce fait il faut assurer la
qualité
avant on s'organisait pour avoir une
confirmation avec le laboratoire de
winnipeg le maintenant le explique eût
pu le faire le faux transiter sur vers
les autres établissements
est ce que je vous dis donc on sait
qu'il faut pas que les gens pensent que
on a le test on on le fait pour
s'assurer des quantités puis il faut
s'assurer de l' expertise plus que
l'aigle et s et je conviens avec les
corps dans les centres soit aussi bon
que celui de l'ex pq mais font face tous
trahis dernière question nadal à la
pause parce que beaucoup de questions là
on sait que 30 dit que des tests partout
disponibles aussi la boxe est pas vrai
que des millions test en attente ils
sont pas ici on essaie en faut combien
de
mieux ou 2 millions de tests puis qui
les fabrique sa cédric sinon on les
fabrique à nous mêmes
de fait ce qu'un moratoire de santé
publique qui a développé ces thèmes avec
les hôpitaux
donc ce sont elles qui est en phase
d'étude mais non je veux vraiment dire
que je pense qu'on était exemplaire en
termes de destinations que se compare
aux échos m nylon et champions parce qu
elle s p qu ils ont développé le test
deux jours après que la séquence était
connue alors c'était extraordinaire
il faut vraiment souligner sentira pas
de pénurie de test et de kits de test
oui on est en caleçon on y étonnement on
pourrait s'en disant et grands
questionnements la la masse de test qui
va s'installer
il faut falloir passer déclare faut
regarder les substrats faut voir sur
pointes est ce qu'il va être organisée
différemment pour les cliniques et là
dessus nous microbiologiste ils ce sont
les laboratoires qui sont dans les gros
centres universitaires vont travailler
qu'elle explique uwe mouche en train de
vous dire qu'actuellement on est capable
de tester on n'a pas de problème
mais si une augmentation importante de
la circulation
on veut faire le diagnostic falloir
remonter de la capacité
on est en train de travailler là-dessus
à la peau non j'ai repensé à la courbe
qu'est le dr arruda avait présentée au
début puis ce test est très parlant mais
merci d'être resté trop là il reste
encore plusieurs minutes à cette émision
émission évidemment plusieurs questions
aussi
c'était une chance poursuit au retour
est avec nous
[Musique]
question de coronavirus poursuit nous
avons reçu des centaines et des
centaines et des centaines de questions
nous essayons de les regrouper soit par
ten pour que vous puissiez bien
informées c'est le but de cette émission
aujourd'hui a eu un appel au calme en
appelle à la solidarité mais aussi un
appel à la prise de conscience de ce qui
se passe réellement voir ce qu'on nous
dit que ça pourrait durer longtemps non
pop pour vous angoisser mais sans doute
pour que chaque citoyen prenne ses
responsabilités mais julie émond a fait
la synthèse de quelques-unes de vos
questions en rafale julie alesi et avec
bien sûr on a synthétisé des questions
qui sont davantage ciblée sur le milieu
de la santé étant donné bien sûr nos
intervenants nos invités sur le plateau
ce soir
en voici trois premières en rafale
d'abord on sait qu'il ya ce fameux
vaccin et on vaccine les jeunes enfants
sur la pneumonie à pneumocoque par
exemple est ce que celui ci serait
efficace pour diminuer les effets
secondaires associés aux coronavirus un
patient dit guéri ans qui a donc réussi
à vaincre la maladie et il ensuite
immunisés est-il encore contagieux que
s'ils demeurent un vecteur donc de
propagation on pose aussi la question
sur ce qu'on appelle l'hygiène la zale
entre ou ce qui est de solution saline
là pour nettoyer justement les
sécrétions nasales
est-ce que ça vraiment un effet pour
diminuer les effets les effets
secondaires du coronavirus et trois
autres rapidement rafa je vous laisserai
sur 7,7 ce tableau pour présenter les
questions aux intervenants
les employés qui sont très très nombreux
dans un lieu on pense à une usine on
pense par exemple à ça le nouvel
peut-être est-ce qu un lieu comme celui
là dans une usine par exemple où il ya
plus de 300 400 employés
est-ce que ça pose des questions de
sécurité là aussi un fonctionnaire par
exemple qui déciderait d'aller en
vacances et qui sait qui sera en
quarantaine forcée payer au retour
comment on juge avait comment on joue
avec tout ça et en terminant pour les
personnes qui sont soit plus vulnérables
ou encore qu'ils sont à mobilité réduite
avons-nous prévu une quelconque trop
sous un moyen
permettre le dépistage à domicile voilà
parle de questions je voulais sont
stables merci je lui dis je commence à
dax un bon présentement il n'ya pas de
vaccin efficace contre le chrono virus
doit des vaccins qui sont elles les
seuils aux 3 3 produits qui sont qui
vont entrer dans des essais cliniques
dans le prochain mois dans le mois qui
suit sur les vrais patriotes sur des
vrais patients des phases dont au juste
pour évaluer la sécurité et ensuite des
phases 2d phase iii ça peut prendre une
année avant qu'on arrive à avoir un
vaccin qui peut être déployée largement
mais il ya quand même des bons prospects
et puis ça regarde bien ceci dit la
vaccination habituel que les enfants
doivent avoir une doivent continuer à la
voir et puis mais ça ne protège pas
contre ce virus là en particulier puis
une chose qui est notable dans cette
maladie là c'est que les gens qui
développent la maladie sévère et qui
décède il ne décide pas de surinfection
bactérienne comparativement à l'
influence
il décède du virus d'un inflammation
massive qui arrivent dans les poumons et
non pas de consulter ces attaques une
personne puisque l'eau non mais on sait
que les personnes plus âgées ils sont
plus vulnérables sont les avoir une
affection que j'avais un parent guérite
patients guérissent et l'immuniser en
théorie oui une fois vous avez guéri de
cette infection est d'être immunisé la
seule chose que la grande question c'est
ce que ce coronavirus va devenir
endémique où va devenir va disparaître
ce que ce que je veux dire par là si
c'est un épisode qui arrive une fois
tout le monde la trappe une grosse
partie de la population il disparaît on
n'entend plus parler un peu comme le
strass il ya quelques années ou bien
c'est un virus qui va muter qui va
s'adapter qui va devenir une forme
d'influenza
c'est à dire que dans les années à venir
il va être là puis va toucher la
population moins sévèrement au
développer des vaccins
et là évidemment l'avenir nous le dira
est ce qu'on aura besoin d'un vaccin il
faut cinq ans une fois aux ânes etc
mais pour l'instant si vous la trappe et
oui vous allez être guéri dans on est
certain de ça on est pas mal certain que
si vous l'avez attrapé vous allez être
guéri vous allez avoir des anticorps et
l'efficacité de l'hygiène nasal qui veut
répond il
une donnée qui dit que c'est plus
efficace ou ça vous protège contre quoi
que ce soit au contraire plus vous vous
touchez le nez plus vous avez de chance
de votre de vous mettre des micros parmi
vous devriez pas met donc à la mouche
l'anil exactement donc si vous passez
votre temps vous nettoyez mener c'est
peut-être pas très bon et les employés
nombreux dans un espace parce que ça a
dû guider votre décision aujourd'hui de
limiter les rassemblements à 250 venus
lui donner ce chiffre mais comme je lui
dis ça n'empêche pas plus
particulièrement quand doit y avoir de
la circulation active de débuter jeudi
le soin parce qu'un 212 qu'on va pour
faire le 8 au pair avec ça puis dans une
pièce qui est très petit
si on est en plein je voudrais situation
où les de la circulation qui est des
gens qui sont enrhumés fait que ces
termes aux policiers d'avoir d'autres
méthodes surtout c'est la réunion n'est
pas absolument essentiel et les
questions de télétravail à des
visioconférences maintenant je pense et
des pratiques faut commencer à instaurer
et qu'ils sont qui vont être bonnes
équipes ont été dans mais faut quand
même être à proximité de la personne
contaminée
oui c'est ça se transmet habitants
durement par gouttelettes en milieu de
soins puis avoir des aérosols teixeira
mai mai puis ça dépend si les gens sont
dans quelle façon vous de leurs
symptômes leurs collègues peut dire mais
il n'y a pas de honte dit absolument
d'être à peu près un vin de menthe et
peut être des personnes mais il n'y a
pas de garantie à 100% mais c'est un
facteur qui joue la question cela
trousses de dépistage c'est intéressant
parce que ça pose la question comment on
fait le dépistage avec les fameux kit ou
les fameux tests la sq c'est une
question pertinente c'est une question
très pertinente peut-être je dirais
qu'il faut mettre en garde la population
de ne pas aller acheter des pseudos kits
de dépistage qui peuvent se vendre sur
l'internet
parce que malheureusement dans ces
situations là tout peut sortir et ça il
ya des choses déjà qu'ils n'ont été
rapportés par rapport à ça dans faut
faire attention
faut vraiment que ce soit bien fait la
façon dont on fait un dépistage
actuellement on prend un écouvillon donc
on prend une espèce de tiges et ont fait
un prélèvement nasopharyngé c'est à dire
qu'on vous met la tige d'années on va
chercher votre pharynx et oraux
pharyngés un petit peu comme une culture
de gorge et on prend ces deux
échantillons là on les met dans un
milieu de transport et on les teste 2
que l'on peut pas faire ça à la maison
aujourd'hui il ya aussi une façon de
bien faire le prélèvement parce que si
on ne fait pas bien on peut avoir un
faux négatifs
donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on va
s'auto faire de pour l'instant à la
maison et bien avant d'aller à la pause
on nous informe que la ligne
téléphonique ne marche pas bien non plus
vocal général merci m'informer c'est
pour ça que vous êtes en contact avec le
terrain on nous dit drapier plus tard
c'est vrai je m'excuse mais on va
apporter des ajustements et j'espère que
mes collègues ce que de ce secteur là
son temps d'écouté très bien merci
encore à tous les quatre on poursuit
cette émission là après la pause va se
joindre aux jets y est
notre spécialiste des fausses nouvelles
et des théories du complot parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de fausses nouvelles et de
désinformation qui circule on avait des
experts aujourd'hui parce important de
s'en remettre à la science pour prendre
les bonnes décisions et adopter les bons
comportements
on se retrouve après la pause reste avec
nous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que le virus c'est la peur
qui se propage en situation de pandémie
mais il ya aussi la désinformation les
fausses nouvelles les théories du
complot ont invité mon collègue jack
james à départager le vrai du faux
journal est spécialisé dans les fausses
nouvelles à l'émission les décrypteurs
bonsoir jeff je pouvais être débordées
depuis le début de crise l'a vraiment
j'ai jamais vu ça ça fait cinq ans que
je couvre les forces nouvelles
j'ai jamais vu ça au temps des
informations autour d'un seul événement
comme ça chez que mes collègues dans les
médias de vérification fait partout dans
le monde mais c'est la même chose on
déborde on reçoit des questions à chaque
jour là dessus ça sur facebook que ce
soit dans le groupe facebook par
courriel des questions vraiment chaque
jour un virus créé un laboratoire client
mais biologique
c'est au début de la crise c'était
autrement les forces nouvelles tourne
autour de sa douce a prévenu que ce
virus là et rapide mal quand ça
commençait à faire les manchettes
on se dit sur l'histoire sur d'où ça
provient ce virus que l'on disait que
une épreuve théorique on ne gouverne ou
sur le chrono viège c'était que ça
connaît d'un laboratoire à winnipeg qui
avait été envoyé secrètement à one par
des supposés espions chinois
ça tient pas la route on voit que les
jambons faux d'information parce que
souvent qu'une crise est clos et qu'une
crise éclate comme ça souvent on n'a pas
toutes les réponses des maisons pas
toutes les réponses encore c'est très
difficile d'aller voir ce retrait en
chine ce qui se passe et dans ce vide
d'information le souvent les gens vont
essayer de nous même trouvé des réponses
en cherchant sur le web puis souvent il
suffit à des sources qui sont pas très
fiables donc vraiment dès le début on
mettait ont jeté le doute sur ça si on
disait que c'était une arme biologique
des toutes sortes de théories comme ça
donc c'est plus profond surtout comme le
sultan palais sentant que c'était
un complot des démocrates il n'est pas
seul au venezuela on dit que c'est un
complot de la cia y est pour miner la
confiance du monde à voir la chine
bref tout le monde sait en accapare bien
sûr provoque pour faire des jeux
politiques comme ça leur avait tout un
défi mais c'est roudet le nouveau grand
défi de communication à tous comme ça c
était nous en santé publique
nos collègues médecins qui qu'ils
connaissent bien aussi piqué ce que vous
voulez l'influencé qui existe depuis des
siècles les coronavirus c'est pas de
complot comme telle mais les gens aiment
utiliser le canard yeux c'est une
exagération des médias sont donc c'est
une idée que la grippe saisonnière
indiquent ces faits il ya une
exagération on en parle beaucoup trop et
au final c'est juste la même chose que
la grippe de la grippe à chaque année à
chaque année des gens qui meurent à
cause de la grippe donc cette idée là
que c'est tout simplement un exagération
cette année pour ce virus lob précis
mais précisons face il y avait peut-être
eu de la confusion due au début les fûts
en ce domaine monsieur tron président ne
vous en faites pas on dit en compte les
risques fm ont dit les français tous
beaucoup plus de monde puis on commence
à dire peut-être que ce virus là va
finir par tuer plus de bon non oui c'est
ça qu'on sait quoi et où la vérité c'est
la proportion finalement océans c'est à
dire ce qu'on sait c'est que ce virus là
son taux de mortalité exact on connaît
pas on dit entre 1 et 3%
c'est pas 10% l'influenza réguliers
saisonniers un taux à 1 to de mentalité
qui oscillent autour de 0 point 1 % le
problème c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que la
mortalité de ce virus là avec ce qu'on
voit en italie surtout dans certains
groupes d'âge n'est pas négligeable mais
comme disait ma collègue cécile en
avance à six maladies qui est très
inflammatoires c'est à dire qui est un
peu bizarre une maladie qu'il ne donne
qui tue les gens par beaucoup de
destructions niveau de leur système
immunitaire
donc c'est quelque chose de nouveau et
c'est un virus qui est inconnue pour
l'espèce humaine
donc on n'a jamais rencontré il faut qu
on l'apprivoisé il faut le reconnaître à
l'apprendre ce qu'on ne connaît avec
l'influent ce don qui est tout ces
éléments là qui font que c'est de plus
difficile de gérer attendait ce qu'on a
fait au début c'est vrai qu'on a comparé
le grenat virus avec l'influenza pour
deux raisons parce que ça se transmet de
la même façon donc c'était pour donner
une idée
jean d'avoir un point de repère pour
pouvoir savoir quelles mesures de
prévention il devait faire puis aussi
pour relativiser les choses parce que
les gens voyaient sur comme une grosse
menace avec les théories du complot et
cetera puis il voyait pas nécessairement
la menace habituel que l'ont acquis et
l'influenza ordinaire ceci dit ces deux
maladies différentes puis plus on
l'épidémie évolue plus on connaît les
manifestations cliniques et on est mieux
capables de cibler aussi les populations
à risques les plus vulnérables donc ça
permet un peu de distinguer les deux
c'est la chaîne que vous en apprend
beaucoup
la chaîne nous en apprend beaucoup ils
ont en fait beaucoup de publications
puis pour les gens sont très critiques
par rapport à la chine qui ont des
raisons de l'être mais y'a pour du point
de vue scientifique
ils ont été très vite quand qui ont
départagé la séquence ça a été très très
important pour tout le reste de la
science et ils ont beaucoup de
publications où on nous décrit les cas
et puis on apprend beaucoup de ça
différents remèdes et quand c'est bidon
alors il ya des gens qui essaient de
profiter de cette crise là en vendant
titre de produit sur les réseaux sociaux
sur le web on a vu elle cette semaine
quelqu'un sur le dark web qui essaie de
vendre un vaccin contre le rotavirus à
400 d'abord bien social fonctionne pas
mais il y aussi de ce tour de remèdes
maison qui circulent donc préparé xavier
gès on a vu aujourd'hui particulièrement
bizarre qui dit que les virils comme un
virus mar 26 degrés celsius dans faux
bois du café du thé pour augmenter sa
température car elle à 26 degrés alors
qu'elle attend près de cinq ans par
jacques est plus haute que ce soit déjà
à la base donc avec une confusion autour
de ça les gens c'est de trouver des
solutions
vu qu'ils obtiendraient pas de vaccin vu
qu'apparemment connu là on cherche déjà
mais de maisons des trucs et des astuces
puis encore là faut pas se fier à des
astuces qu'on voit dans nos publications
facebook dans une image ou vraiment se
fier aux autorités et
et à l'information pour enchaîner quand
même monsieur 30 jeudi qu'avec la
chaleur ça partirait et aujourd'hui vous
vous avez dit d'autres zoos en point de
presse
au printemps il va peut-être s'en aller
puis peut-être revenir à l'automne
dallas ont pu grâce parce qu il va faire
chaud il va s'en aller mais c'est sûr
associé au cidre et puis je les sais où
sont mes collègues ont complété les
virus sont des saisonnalité
habituellement si ces essais c'est connu
puis parents du nouveau virus par des
comportements différents dans la chaîne
on a eu une première vague au printemps
loyat pas absolument de l' influence
puis onu après sony à quel niveau
survenue à l'automne mais je vous dis
possible les problématiques se perd et
ça va ralentir un peu sa course y danse
de transmission puis revenir à l'eau à
l'automne puis est-ce qu'il va après saw
ii comme 19 ans tantôt disparaître ou au
sein des petits là les populations
humaines que devenir son appel endémique
un brin virus comme les autres comme un
navire russe on a actuellement d'autres
éléments jeff beck
je pense que bon on parle beaucoup de
change les comportements en société pour
empêcher la propagation de ce virus nous
je pense qu'on a aussi on doit changer
nos comportements sur les réseaux
sociaux donc je dirai tout le monde qui
nous écoutent dans ce moment fait
vraiment attention à ce que vous
partagez sur les réseaux sociaux
si vous jouez à des médias et des
sources gouvernementales des services de
santé publique que vous connaissez donc
de ne pas payer le reste du canada et
aussi des médias que vous connaissez
personnellement sur le web on voit des
médias de partout au monde
on les connaît pas tous donc partagé pas
des articles de médias que vous ne
connaissez pas très bien donc rester
avec des sources d'information fiables
quelqu'un ac auquel vous fait confiance
et ne partagez pas des publications qui
mettent de l'avant des remèdes des
photos des vidéos qui était le voici ce
qui se passe at elle eu lieu dans le
monde
c'est trop facile de détourner des
photos des vidéos comme ça on a vu plein
de photos et vidéos qui ont été mal
interprétés kiko juste une panique
généralisée donc on fait vraiment
vraiment attention
on change nos comportements sur des
réseaux sociaux pour empêcher la
propagation de la désinformation sur le
clavier
us comme on change de comportement dans
la société pour empêcher la propagation
vous savez je suis un mot là-dessus
madame vous vouliez dire que je vous
remercie parce que je les dis souvent
que vous allez c'est madame qui est
bluffant
merci de patti smith un jour parce qu'on
a besoin de la collaboration des gens on
n'a pas besoin de les faire paniquer et
de leur faire faire des choses qui sont
pas des quads grosse erreur de se
croiser très important puis je pense
qu'il pourrait peut-être y avoir une
directive nationale d'identifier des
sources crédibles parce que
effectivement si c'est quand même
difficile pour la population de
distinguer le bon grain de l'ivraie
je vous dirais quelqu'un qui a peur
c'est quelqu'un qui est vulnérable et
qui est plus crédules
donc c'est quelqu'un qui va être portée
justement à croire un petit peu un petit
peu tout ce qui se passe alors dernière
rafale pour ce soir julie duclos
rapidement de mari plusieurs parents de
jeunes enfants dont je fais partie se
demandent les c'est bien beau les écoles
seront fermées qu'en est il des
garderies cette question revient
beaucoup à partir de quand en incubation
le virus dans notre corps peut-il être
dépistés à la déteste et enfin qu'en est
il de nos téléphones cellulaires cet
objet qu'on a toujours à la main qui
n'est pas nécessairement propre voire
une retraire était le moyen de bien le
nettoyer devient le désinfecter parce
que ça peut devenir un objet de
transmission dont voici trois pistes que
je vous soulèvent merci je dis alors
garderie s'inscrit on voit évoluer
actuellement les massifs mais ce n'est
même pas en garderie volet on peut les
départs on peut déplacer le problème
ailleurs et des enjeux comme ça il faut
puis en garderie on peut probablement
appliquer des mesures des gens parlent
de mes os d'hygiène et de prévention qui
sont là demeure encore une fois évalué
selon lui pu tester incubation de la
période maximale d'incubation est de 14
jours en moyenne c'est de cinq jours
donc on peut dire qu'en moyenne
les symptômes vont se manifester et donc
on va pouvoir dépister la maladie à peu
près dans la période de cinq jours des
petits conseils des trucs la question
des nettoyages des téléphones
cellulaires mais ça c'est à devrait être
élémentaire c'est ce qu'on a dit depuis
tout le temps là de l'hygiène
l'étiquette respiratoire nettoyer les
objets inanimés la même façon et pour
vous un conseil à la peur rend les gens
souvent très individualiste si on veut
vraiment se protéger il faut avoir une
vision collective actuellement bon pour
vous le mot de la fin
mais moi je pense qu'ensemble je pense
qu'ensemble on va être capable de passer
à travers ça s'assume et il faut falloir
que chacun y mette la mairie chaque
petit geste est utile se laver les mains
si tu dis ben oui c'est moi je pense
qu'un projet de société il faut qu'on
soit tous solidaires et qu'on travaille
dans le même sens que ce soit au niveau
scientifique mais surtout au niveau
humain et à partir de là je pense qu'on
va essayer de limiter la courbe que vous
avez montré initialement et la mettre la
plus plate possible pour que justement
on est loin d'un impact sur la société
en général parce qu'on pense que vous
allez de travaux doit parler à vos
collègues des autres provinces parce
qu'il y aura des défis particuliers
continuent à parler avec les gens
d'ottawa
oui on savoir quelles mesures
additionnelles l'on peut prendre parce
consacré au québec on est peut-être plus
proactifs rigoureux est exact à ces
éléments mais on va bien entendu quand
ça concerne sénégal est le point de l'
influence mais on veut aussi ne pas se
faire par alizée et agir non seulement
comme et des conseils de mise en
isolement pour tous les gens qui
reviennent le voyage
avec un fil que soit le pays mettant
doit se mettre en isolement à partir de
mai exactement
merci à vous quatre ou cinq d'avoir
participé à cette émission spéciale qui
étaient là pour informer le public et
demain à 24,70 aura encore une émission
de deux heures mais je vous rappelle
quand même que toutes les écoles sont
fermées en ontario demain toujours pas
de directives de québec concernant les
écoles mais avec cependant tendus ce
soir on va ce sera l écoute de 24.5
demain des informations ils doivent
d'abord des nouvelles de ce côté là
d'ailleurs plusieurs commissions
scolaires ont annoncé qu'elles seront
fermés demain et des collèges privés
également merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission nous étions là pour vous
informer répondre à cet appel au calme
et à la solidarité puis à l'accord par
la conviction qu'il faut bien s'informer
voilà c'est tout pour ce soir reste à
l'antenne pour le téléjournal avec
céline galipeau à demain 19h pour deux
heures en comptant et vos questions
[Musique]